- Hey guys, how is the
going ? Happy holidays !
I am back here with my sister,
- Hello!
- This is Jennae.
- Today we are drinking out
of our Star Laboratories mugs.
I was watching The Flash,
which I absolutely love.
Season two, Dr. Wales, I'm only
on Season 2, so no spoilers,
but he was drinking out of one
of these mugs and I was like,
(both take deep breath)
I wanna drink out of one of those, too.
- I was actually here, that happened,
she's like, I want one of those, too!
Gets on the internet,
showed up, she's like,
"I forgot I ordered this!"
Cheers.
- Cheers.
Anyway, we got our mugs, but
today we're doing nothing
that has to do with The
Flash, or anything really.
- Why are we wearing festive sweaters?
What are we even doing today?
- It's the holiday season
and we are celebrating
all of December its Vlogmas, sort of,
I'm sort of vlogging everyday.
- I've missed a lot of days.
- I'm not sure.
- Oh!
The future maker.
- What?
- Fortune.
(mumbles)
- So, this is a fortune cookie maker,
and spoiler alert, I've
actually made these before.
Me and Jordan made these once,
but it wasn't even for a video,
it was actually just for fun
to see if we could make them.
And now here we are,
Jennae is gonna assist me
because this process is kind of crazy!
- Uh, you told me it was easy!
- Yeah, we burned ourselves so many times,
like, it's kind of insane
and it's really kind of hard
to do, so I lied to you.
- What, you burn yourself?
- Mmmm.
- Is that in the instructions, burn self?
- You don't wanna do it, but you do.
- can I make my own fortune?
- Yes, custom fortune cookies.
- Oh, my good ...
- There's an edible marker
that this comes with.
- I have to write the fortunes?
There's not like, a label maker?
- (whispers) I have a label maker.
- So, what I thought
would be a cool idea's
if you made these you could
do little gifts for people.
you could put like a little
gift certificate inside of it,
so, like if you get somebody
an Amazon gift card,
you can just like, write
the Amazon gift card code
and you could put it
in the fortune cookie.
- What if they don't open it?
- Then they, they missed
out on their present.
- What if the ink runs?
- Then, they missed,
um, these are questions
that are just to in to depth
for what I feel like
going in to right now.
- Let's open it!
- Okay.
- Here we go!
- Yay!
- Oooh!
- Fortune fun.
- What's this?
- I'm just here, I'm literally
just here for the cookie.
I need a T shirt that says,
I'm just here for the cookies!
- That doesn't mean
what you think it means.
- Does it means something else?
- Yes.
- It's gettin' lit in this
kitchen, look at this.
- Wow!
- Bam, bam, bam,
- I need more of my water.
- Bam, bam, bam, bam,
- Bam, bam.
- So this is a paper.
- Trash.
- That is like edible paper,
I think it's FD ...
- Prove it!
Take a bite out of it right now.
- FDA approved, well, no,
it's not, you can't eat it,
but it's like FDA approved
to put next to food.
- You said edible paper.
Check the back.
- I retract it.
I retracted it.
- Take it, take a bite,
You said it you must eat the paper.
- I retract my statement, okay cool.
- Here's all of our little
goodies we've gotten here,
that this comes with.
We've got like, a little scooper,
we've got a little flipper,
we've got an edible marker.
Look here's a caution for us:
Cookies are hot.
Be careful, handling cookies
during the folding process.
So to make our fortune cookie recipe
we are gonna need five
tablespoons of unsalted butter,
one cup superfine sugar,
one pinch of salt,
four large egg whites,
one cup all purpose flour,
five tablespoons of milk,
one teaspoon vanilla extract,
non-cooking spray.
- Non-cooking spray?
(laughs)
- What's non-cooking spray?
- Non-stick.
- We need non-cooking
spray, we need spray.
Do I put this in the bowl?
- Not yet, we have to melt this.
So get that melted up.
- So, can I put it in the bowl?
- No, melt it, put it in ...
- Can I ...
- I don't ... put it another
bowl and melt the bowl.
- Is there a reason?
- Yes, because ...
- Tell me it.
- Because I have to put
in the dry ingredients,
I'm not sure actually.
I don't really have any answer for you,
I'm getting flustered.
- Forgot about the butter.
- Oh no!
- Its super wet.
- That's okay, it needed
to be melted, very melted.
- Whaa!
- Combine egg whites and sugar.
(bangs eggs on bowl)
- You dummy.
- It was supposed to be egg whites.
I'm an absolute idiot,
I knew this as well.
- Well, you said it!
- I did say it.
- Slowly.
(mixer running)
I like the smell of sugar.
I do not like the smell of burnt butter!
(mixer running)
- This is looking very nice.
Yes, thank you.
- Yes, spatula,
(both yelling) Yes!
(upbeat music in background)
- Let's go wild!
We need five tablespoons of milk,
it might be expired .
Expired, please don't be expired.
- How many, I said five.
- Five!
- We need to mix in the
vanilla, vanilla-nilla!
- How much?
- (sings) Shimmy, shimmy,
cocoa pop, listen to me now.
- Teaspoon or table?
- Teaspoon.
The first mix is slowest
(sings) Baby, I know ...
Touch that, I swear ...
- Could you imagine if
I just cut your hair.
- No, it's all I have going for me.
Okay, we need to write
out our fortune cookies.
- Am I making this for you?
- We can, or we can make
it for whoever we want!
I know I've got other
edible markers in here.
'Cause like, who doesn't
have multiple edible makers?.
Okay, this one's gonna be for
Nick, he's behind the camera.
- I wanna make one for him, too.
- Okay, well, I think we have
enough just to get us started.
That's actually great!
- It's a good one!
(lid slams shut)
Oh, I spelled it wrong.
(spray sound)
Fold as directed.
Do not open the fortune cookie maker
before the recommended ...
(mumbles)
So don't open it before 2 minutes.
- It is 2 minutes.
- (both yelling) Alexa stop!
- This smells really bad
- Where the hell'd they go?
- Where'd they go?
- Oh god, wow!
- Oh my gosh, it's a crispy!
- So, that's something that's
not supposed to happen.
- Oh my god, the smell, the stench!
- Oh god, it's burning.
This looks really bad!
That's not right.
- I just realized how completely
worthless I am in this video.
- Its cool!
- I'm just like here, and then I'm here,
and then I'm over here.
- This is going not as
well as it did before.
- It could just be the first couple
that need to get that plastic crap off.
- Yeah, we need to just ... It's true.
- We gotta warm it up!
- I think I should check on them.
- You can't, it says do not
open before the 2 minutes!
- Okay, okay, okay!
(screaming)
God, is it hot!
This whole thing is ,
like that's how its
supposed to be happening.
Holy moly!
Oh gosh, these are hot!
Then you just like, fold it up like that,
oh God its burning!
Its burning my flesh!
- I wanna make one, get outta my way.
Do I have to spray it again?
- Here, here, here, ow!
- I meant like, make my own.
- this is a practice, this is a practice.
- This is horrible!
- Oh gosh!
Who ever thought this
was gonna work out well?
- Ooo, it tastes good!
- Really?
Oh wow, yeah!
Give me another hit of that.
Oh yeah, that's good!
- I couldn't break it because it ...
- Oh my gosh!
(spoon tapping)
- Are we gonna put a fortune in it?
- yes, okay this looks good so far.
(deep inhale) its so hot,
it's so incredibly hot!
Okay, so I've got this ready,
is that what it's supposed to
look like? (soft happy music)
- Nailed it!
Oh god, my fingers!
- Alexa, stop!
- There's holes burned in to my finger.
- Oh god, I can't get it out!
Okay.
- Oh!
- Oh, wow, okay, that one
needed a little more batter.
This is difficult.
Yes, yes, slay.
- Come do some easier,
do you want to melt up our chocolate?
- I'm busy, I just got an email.
- Half power, three minutes
, check on it every minute!
No, see, you have to
put in the minutes first
and then the power level.
I made a wonton.
- Why?
- I messed up.
- My favorite thing is when
you made a pumpkin pie.
- Oh my god!
- Who in the world was like ...
- I told you it was too much.
- This is so upsetting!
- Its not ideal.
Like a little mini pancake.
- Ow, These are hot!
- I don't want to touch it.
Ow!
- Its so unbelievably hot!
Okay, here we go, look at that.
Did you see that perfection?
This is absolute fortune
cookie perfection.
Do you remember the simple
instruction that I gave you also?
We have to check on the
chocolates at every minute.
- Well, I already missed
two of the minutes.
- I know!
What is this?
Oh no, its gonna be fine once we ...
- Yeah, here, no stop.
- No, no, my cookie!
That's for Nick, he's gonna be very upset.
- Oh my gosh!
- Wow! Put your hand on
it, I'll give you 10 bucks.
- Ten?
- 10 dollars.
- Let me think about it.
It's not even worth the hospital bill.
Look at that, Now that I've got
this technique down I am ...
- It's too buttery.
- Whee, okay well, that looks good.
I'll put that in there.
- Look what I have, a dog!
- Hi, honey.
- Mummy's making mess.
- Can you give me kiss?
- When I was cleaning,
I pushed the fortune cookie machine,
and I burned myself so bad,
like my finger is actually
burning right now,
like it hurts, it doesn't,
you can't really tell,
but my gosh it hurts.
- Crime.
- Okay, here's our fortune cookies.
- Oops!
We got the hang of it after a little ...
- No, I forgot to fold those.
- That's a pancake.
But we actually got the hang of it,
like, look how good these look.
- There were some mistakes
that I was making.
Number one, I was using
way too much spray.
When I stopped using so much spray
things worked out quite well.
Oh, my finger hurts so bad.
Okay, so, basically
were' re just gonna dip.
You gonna watch me dip?
- Are you gonna open yours
when I make it for you?
- Yeah!
We need a presentation plate.
look at that, that looks
absolutely beautiful.
Lets see if I have something
else we can decorate.
- This is yours, my dear sister.
- My dear sister.
- Could your help me to
open this, I have an injury.
- There, there, there now.
- I got hurt today guys, I got an injury.
Look at this one, we're gonna
give him a nice little dip.
Oh, my finger hurts really bad.
You're gonna be hearing
about this for like a week.
- Yeah, she had the flu
once and it was like ooooh,
actually no, not even the
flu, she had like, a cold,
like the most common of colds.
- I was so ill.
- And it was like someone
beat her with a bat.
- I got, I have it, I get a sickness,
I make sure everyone knows about it.
- Look at this, dual cookie.
- Wow , that looks nice Jen.
- Thank You!
- Can you open that one?
Thank you.
- I have an injury.
- This is the same color.
- Yeah, but they're gems.
I'm injured so I can't open it.
- Oh No! It started.
Oh, look at this, wow!
- Oops!
- Well, I used them all on one.
So, now what?
- Wow, That's too much!
Here, I'll make it.
No, I hate it, I don't like it.
- I think it looks good.
I can't touch anything
because my finger hurts.
- Oh my god, how many are we up to?
Three now, pink and plains.
Oh, we can make a crepe!
- Are we still filming?
(giggles)
- [Nick] Oh, yeah.
- I just want to eat.
Let's end this video.
- I'm making a crepe.
- [Nick] You guys are
going in on this shit.
I've never seen you guys,
like, actually eat the stuff,
like, you're enjoying it.
- It's so good!
- [Nick] Can I have a plate?
- You wanna come be in our video?
- [Nick] Sure!
- Here you go.
- [Nick] Okay, which one is it?
- Okay, the black one.
- Like my soul.
- Yes.
- There we go.
- Its still, its still sticky.
- I'm so excited.
- Well, if you want...
- You can open this one.
- I'm excited, it looks like a, whoo,
- Taste this, taste this first.
- Taste it?
- Yeah, because there's
no chocolate on it.
Is that how you eat a fortune cookie?
- No, how are you
- I thought you're supposed to
- This is really good!
- Right, why do you think we're
literally eating everything.
- This is really good!
- Here, this is for you, I think,
if its not then we have to find ...
- Do I eat it or open it?
- Um, open it.
- We should open it, yeah.
- Why don't all fortune
cookies taste like this?
- I don't know, but they're really good!
- Why am I covered in crap?
- We're gonna eat these first,
right, or it's bad luck?
- Yeah, but you're not supposed to,
so, guys Nick ate something that I baked
not too long ago and got food poisoning.
- He got food poisoning.
- So, you were not supposed to
eat anything that I ever made again.
- I had a dairy for a year.
- Had a dairy for a year.
- What a contradiction.
- Oops!
- Yeah, well, cancel.
- Okay, that one's for you, it's really,
it's probably not dry yet.
What the heck is this?
I can't open it because my thumb hurts.
- Oh my, get a hammer.
- I got ya.
- you will pay Jennae the
money you owe her, Ooh!
- Aah!
- Fortune fun.
- Oh no, you will find a
clown hidden somewhere.
(girls gasp)
- Don't bring me in on that.
- I have to ice my thumb
because I've got a booboo.
- I'm starting to get a
blister, look at my injury.
- Seven, hot to touch.
- Oh look, see it?
- Oh I do, You wanna pop it with a needle?
- Eww, Noooooo!
- Alright guys, thank
you so much for watching.
Hope you guys enjoyed this video.
Happy Holidays, Merry Christmas,
whatever it is that you celebrate,
I hope that you are celebrating
it with festivity and style.
- I've got both of those things!
- Make sure that you go
check out Jennae's channel,
and yeah, that's, that's a wrap.
- Oh I've got a tummy ache,
I had too many sweets.
- These were so good
though, I can't believe it,
we finally got the hang of it at the end.
- We need to work on
our decorating though,
' cause this is trash.
- We do, hmmm.
- Alright I'll see you
guys in the next video,
we'll have a bunch more holiday
videos coming out very
shortly, so, stay tuned.
Happy Vlogmas, sort of, video,
everyday in December, or until Christmas.
- Vlog maybe.
- Vlog, mmm ...
- Maybe vlog.
- Vlogmeh, vlogmeh!
Welcome to Vlogmeh!
- Okay, bye.
(Christmas music)